Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Elf Spieltage sind absolviert in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Und ach, es ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Wir müssen darüber sprechen. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es ist wieder soweit. Wir wollen auf die 2. Männer-Bundesliga blicken. Da ist, wie gerade schon so gesagt, mal wieder ein bisschen Gesprächsbedarf vorhanden. Und deshalb freue ich mich sehr, dass ihr hier eingeschaltet habt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Und ich begrüße jetzt bei mir zwei Stimmen, die ihr aus der 2. Liga, also 2. Männer-Liga-Podcast-Welt schon kennen könntet. Zum einen Tim Ecksteen. Er ist Sportjournalist. Er ist beim Millern-Ton zu hören. Er ist auf Twitter der Ed-Tim-Ecksteen. Also nicht so wahnsinnig kreativ, aber umso mehr informativ in seinen Beiträgen. Schön, dass du hier bist, Tim.
Ja, unbedingt. Das war sicherlich so. Also gerade nach dieser Pressekonferenz, glaube ich nach dem Spiel gegen St. Pauli, als er nach dem Matchplan gefragt wurde, den der Kollege damals nicht erkannt hatte, da ist ja wirklich viel von diesem alten weißen Männerhass auf ihn eingepasselt, obwohl es, wenn man sich die Antworten mal mit etwas Verstand angehört hat, war es ja wirklich sehr einfach verständlich und die Hürde zum Verständnis hin nicht besonders hoch. Er hatte, glaube ich, nicht so wirklich Bock auf Medienarbeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alte, gute Red Bull-Schule ist. Er hat aber, ich finde, in diesen zwei, ein Viertel, zweieinhalb Jahren sich in der Hinsicht durchaus gesteigert und vor allem hat er praktisch nie bis sehr selten Bullshit erzählt. Man konnte Robert Klaus tatsächlich Dinge fragen und er hat die Frage beantwortet und musste sich nicht in 700 Floskeln oder Phrasen flüchten und das fand ich immer sehr angenehm. Wenn es eine Scheißfrage war, dann hat er die auch so beantwortet, aber trotzdem nicht in diesen wirklich langweiligen Trainer-Phrasen Deutsch, dass der Einsatz stimmen muss und Kratzen beißen und so was. Es waren immer sehr interessante Antworten. Er hat vor der ersten Pokalrunde den 1. FC Kahn Marienborn, die – ich kann mich schon gar nicht mehr erinnern, ich glaube jetzt Regionalliga oder Oberliga spielen – auf jeden Fall hat er die auch in der Pressekonferenz so seziert, taktisch wie er es sonst halt bei der normalen Zweitligakonkurrenz macht. Also da war auch viel Ernsthaftigkeit und Respekt dem jeweiligen Gegner gegenüber immer zu verspüren. Also ich persönlich fand die Arbeit mit ihm zunehmend angenehmer hier in Nürnberg. Gegen nicht allen Kollegen so kann ich in vielen Fällen verstehen, weil wie gesagt, manchmal konnte man seine Art durchaus als etwas schnippisch interpretieren. War sie aber in meinen Augen nicht. Also ich fand es immer angenehmer. Aber das war schon sowas, was dann bei vielen im Umfeld auch den Reflex, haha, jetzt mal weg mit dem. Und der Bubi-Laptop-Trainer und sowas.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, da muss ich dir voll zustimmen. Diese Pressekonferenzen mit Robert Klauß, die sind echt richtig erfrischend gewesen. Das fand ich nämlich auch immer, wenn St. Pauli gegen Nürnberg gespielt hat, da habe ich das natürlich auch vor und nach den Spielen verfolgt. Und da war es echt auffällig, dass man wenig diese typischen Phrasen gehört hat und viel wirklich spielspezifische Antworten, wo man doch auch schon so eine Liebe zum Detail bei ihm auch gemerkt hat, dass er da sich wirklich intensiv mit was befasst und sich auch – also, ja, so eine gegenseitige – also wirklich so ein Zeichen des Respekts, dass man da – dass er die Frage im Grunde so zurückgespiegelt hat, wie sie kam. Also wenn es eine blöde Frage war, dann hat er sie auch – na ja, da hat er sie mehr oder minder abhundariert. Aber wenn er das Gefühl hatte sozusagen, da hat jemand sich Gedanken gemacht und will auch was hinaus, dann ist er darauf auch eingegangen und hat sich – also hat wirklich, wie du sagst, ehrlich die Frage beantwortet und auch vielleicht gerade heraus auch immer häufig das gesagt, was er denkt und das ist ihm ja auch das eine oder andere mal so ein bisschen auf die Füße gefallen.
Ja, und es ist also tatsächlich, es muss ein Trainer jetzt vielleicht nicht der rhetorische Überflieger sein, aber wenn man sich dann diese Antrittspressekonferenz mit Markus Weinzierl anhört, da hatte man so das Gefühl, der ballert in 20 Minuten jetzt all die Phrasen raus, die sich Robert Klaus 2, 5 Jahre vom Mund abgespart hat irgendwie. Und wie gesagt, es langt noch nicht um eine Meinung, sich zu bilden über Markus Weinzierl, aber der Unterschied war deutlich in der öffentlichen Darstellung seiner selbst.
Aber woran ist Nürnberg denn gescheitert eigentlich? Also woran ist Klaus dann gescheitert? Also ich meine, letzte Saison war das offensiv auch immer noch kein Spektakel, aber ich hatte eigentlich gedacht, die haben das Mittelfeld ja doch zusammengehalten, ja gut, bis auf Tom Kraus, aber die haben ja eigentlich mit Dua und Daferna zwei Stürmer geholt, von denen man gesagt hat, das sind die Puzzleteile, die fehlen bei Nürnberg.
Ja, beide sehr begeistert aufgenommen wurden hier in Nürnberg, Dua und Daferna, jetzt sind die Zweifel ein bisschen größer geworden, weil sie nicht so wirklich ins Spiel eingebunden werden. Ich glaube, das war das große Problem, dass es so die offensive Idee Robert Klauß nie hat entwickeln können. In den besten Momenten hier in Nürnberg war das auch immer eine Mannschaft von Robert Klauß, die dann auch mit Wucht und sich selbst begeistern irgendwie ins Spiel gefunden hat. Und ein ganz großer Fehler, auf den vor der Saison ein paar Menschen hier in Nürnberg hingewiesen haben, der aber von den meisten ignoriert wurden, weil alle, unter anderem auch ich, auf Dua und Daferna mit glänzenden Augen geblickt haben, ist einfach, dass im defensiven Mittelfeld einer fehlt, der so ein Spiel ein bisschen ordnen kann. Im Verein dachten sie, das macht Johannes Geiss, der aber zu oft inzwischen beweist, dass er ein bisschen zu langsam ist für diesen Fußball in der zweiten Liga. Und dann gibt es da einfach keinen. Also jetzt versuchen sie es dann immer mal wieder mit einer Doppel-Sex, mit wechselndem Personal, das irgendwie aufzufangen. Es ist immer fachfremdes Personal. Lino Tempelmann ist einmal Fabian Nürnberger, beide eher 8er, der einzige, der wirklich noch ein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler oder ein 6er ist, ist Sadik Fofana, eine Leihgabe, aber eben auch erst 19 Jahre jung. Der muss jetzt sehr viel Verantwortung übernehmen, macht das defensiv gut, aber ist im Spiel nach vorne auch keiner, der sich da jetzt sonderlich viel zutraut, was logisch ist. Und das ist so, glaube ich, das größte Problem, das in den Momenten in Nürnberg um die Ohren fliegt, dass da einer fehlt auf der Position. Dann gibt es noch so ein paar andere Baustellen, wie die Außenverteidiger einerseits bedingt durch den Ausfall von Tim Handwerker mit seinem Kreuzbandriss und so. Das haben Dieter Hecking und Olaf Rebbe, die sich ja zu zweit um die Kaderplanung kümmern, bisher immer so ein bisschen abgetan als Schmaden. Und jetzt neuerdings hört man auch von den beiden, dass sie jetzt im Winter mal gucken wollen, ob sich da nicht doch noch irgendwo einer findet, der die Position spielen kann.
Ja, lass doch gerne mal über die beiden sprechen, denn jetzt haben wir über die Trainerfrage schon kurz gesprochen. Ich glaube, wie gesagt, Weinzell ist jetzt zu kurz da, um da jetzt Annahmen zu treffen, die über Vermutungen hinausgehen. Aber gerade die Rolle von Dieter Hecking und auch Olaf Rebbe, die ist ja interessant, auch in dieser Doppelkonstellation. Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl in der Stellung von Dieter Hecking vor allem. Also der hat sein Wort, hat ein großes Gewicht. Man war auch meiner Auffassung nach sehr stolz, dass er zum Club gekommen ist. Und gleichzeitig hat er sich ja aber sehr lange auch vor Robert Kraus gestellt. Und damit ja auch so ein bisschen jetzt nicht sein Schicksal mit seinem verknüpft. Das ist immer so eine Floske, die mir sagt, das ist jetzt zu viel in diesem Fall. Aber dennoch merkt man jetzt auch hier in der Diskussion, wir sprechen jetzt nicht mehr nur über den Trainer, wir sprechen auch über so Fragen der Kaderzusammenstellung und eben Fehler oder vielleicht auch Fehleinschätzungen, die da passiert sind. Welche Stellung hat er gerade im Verein?
Im Verein glaube ich eine relativ gute. Sein Vertrag soll jetzt sehr zeitnah noch verlängert werden. Nur rund um den Verein wächst die Skepsis natürlich. Die gab es zu Beginn seiner Amtszeit hier eher nicht. Da waren wirklich alle sehr froh, dass Dieter Hecking nach Nürnberg, der große Dieter Hecking, zum tief gefallenen 1. FC Nürnberg zurückkommt und sich dessen annimmt. Was Hecking damals geschafft hat, muss man im Hoch anrechnen, ist tatsächlich den Verein so ein bisschen zu beruhigen. Weil es war damals mit diesen Relegationsspielen doch alles sehr aufgelegt und mit seinem Vorgänger Robert Palikucar. Also es war sehr viel durcheinander und da muss man sagen, Dieter Hecking hat es sehr gut hinbekommen. Ich fand auch die Einstellung von Robert Klauß überraschend mutig damals, womit ich so meine Probleme oder wo ich meine Bedenken hatte, ob Dieter Hecking, der zweifelsohne ein sehr guter Fußballtrainer war oder ist, ob der auch das strategische Denken mitbringt, dass es vielleicht für einen Sportvorstand braucht. Die Zweifel habe ich immer noch. Die Zweifel gab es offenbar auch im Verein, weil man Dieter Hecking gesagt hat, er darf sich gerne noch jemanden zur Seite holen. Dass er das dann mit Olaf Rebbe getan hat, hat im Verein dann doch einige überrascht, weil Olaf Rebbe ja eher das Feld abdeckt, von dem er dachte, in dem kennt sich auch Dieter Hecking gut aus, nämlich in dieser Spielersuche und Kaderplanung. Man dachte, er holt sich einen zur Seite, der mehr so für das strategische Entwickeln des Vereins zuständig ist. Ja, also eine etwas komische Konstellation. Ich hätte mir jetzt von Dieter Hecking gewünscht, dass er ein bisschen länger das mit diesem Trainer durchhält, zumal er erst im Sommer den Vertrag mit Robert Klauß verlängert hat. Meine Skepsis ist nicht weniger geworden, eher ein bisschen gewachsen, ob das so eine coole Besetzung dieser Position Sportvorstand ist. Aber noch bin ich damit in Nürnberg eine Minderheit.
Ja, ich meine, was ich interessant finde, ist – das wäre jetzt auch das Letzte, was ich dich noch fragen würde, sonst wird das hier zu lange – aber wenn wir jetzt mal die Häme abziehen, und die vielleicht auch Markus Weins hier nicht verdient hat, denn meine Güte, der ist ein erfolgreicher Trainer, erfolgreicher als ganz viele andere Trainer, und nur weil der breiten Masse der Fußball oder vielleicht auch die Vereine nicht gefällt, bei denen er mal trainiert hat. Ja, das ist halt dann so. Aber da, finde ich, muss man dann auch so ein bisschen was abziehen. Aber was man ja schon festhalten kann, glaube ich, ist, dass es einen deutlichen Wechsel in der Spielidee zu geben scheint. Und das ist dann ja letztlich auch so ein strategisches Thema, wie du es gerade angesprochen hast. Kannst du dir denn erklären, wie Markus Weinzel zu dem passen soll, wie bisher der Kader gebaut wurde? Und ist vielleicht dieser Wechsel in der Spielidee gar nicht so krass, wie er für mich aussieht? Weil ich eben das Gefühl hatte, dass Robert Klauß jemand war, der eigentlich auch viel über Pressing und Intensität und Umschaltfußball und vertikalem Fußball spielen lassen will. Und Markus Weinziel ist jemand, der zumindest in seinen letzten Stationen und vor allem jetzt zuletzt auch beim FC Augsburg zwar auch Umschaltfußball spielen lassen will, aber tief aus der eigenen Hälfte heraus. Also das ist kein Angriffspressing, was da gespielt wird. Und dementsprechend brauchst du ja auch extrem schnelle Spieler, Spieler, die es auch schaffen, aus diesen Situationen heraus dann präzise lange Bälle zu spielen. Du brauchst vielleicht einen Zielspieler vorne drin, der auch mal eine Ablage machen kann, einen Ball festmachen kann, bis alle anderen nachgerückt sind. Passt das denn zu dem, was er da vorfindet beim Klub?
So wie du es gerade sagst, nein.
Hoffentlich irre ich mich.
So wie es am Wochenende ausgesehen hat, kann es funktionieren, natürlich. Das ist schwierig. Die Spielidee beim 1. FC Nürnberg war ja gerade eben nicht mehr so wirklich zu erkennen. Vielleicht ist es da vollkommen egal, mit welcher Spielidee einer nach Nürnberg kommt und versucht, etwas Neues anzufangen. Schnell ist die Mannschaft, bis auf Quattrodur wirklich nicht. Lino Tempelmann vielleicht noch mit Abstrichen. Kann ich schwierig einschätzen. Das ist so eine Tim-Frage. Die muss der jetzt aus dem Off nochmal beantworten. Aber ich bin auch da skeptisch. Aber lass mich gerne überraschen. Ich bin da nicht so vorurteilsfrei wie du, was Markus Weinziel betrifft. Du bist da Vornehmer.
Also grundsätzlich würde ich ja sagen, was Markus Weinziel betrifft, ich habe jetzt auch nicht gedacht, wow, da hat der FCN jetzt einen Trainer geholt, der richtig für einen speziellen Fußball steht. Aber genau das ist ja vielleicht auch bei vielen Trainern auch gar nicht so der Fall, weil was man ja auch immer vergisst, ist, dass viele Trainer ja auch durchaus nicht unbedingt nur für einen Fußball stehen. Also es sind ja nicht alle Tim Walters sozusagen, die immer so einen ganz radikalen Fußball denken, sondern die meisten Trainer versuchen ja einfach, das Beste aus einem Kader zu machen. Und wenn Markus Weinzier eben gar nicht die Möglichkeit hat, aus dem Kader ein ballbesitzorientiertes, offensiv kreatives Team zu machen, dann ist das eben so. Und irgendwann kommt man natürlich als Trainer auch in so eine Schublade. Stichwort Michael Schiele, der eben diesen krassen Umschaltfußball spielen lässt. Und dann wird man sagen, ja, für den Fußball braucht man jemanden wie Michael Schiele. Dass so ein Trainer vielleicht noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten hätte, auch in seinem Kopf drin, das wird ja bei vielen häufig gar nicht so weiter gedacht. Also ich finde, so ein Trainerwechsel allgemein, finde ich, mitten in der Saison, Trainerwechsel, ist immer ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Fehlerkultur in einem Verein vielleicht gar nicht so gut funktioniert. Es sei denn, es ist ein Trainer, der sich massiv vergriffen hat im Ton oder massive Fehler gemacht hat oder auf einmal bocklos zum Training kommt oder so. Aber gerade weil du auch gesagt hast, dass da im Sommer der Vertrag verlängert wurde, sowas finde ich dann ganz schwierig. Und da ist immer ganz schwierig gerade diese Verbindung, und die finde ich auch ähnlich zum FC St. Pauli tatsächlich, die Verbindung mit ja, okay, bei der Transferpolitik ist vielleicht auch nicht so viel richtig gelaufen. Und dann da natürlich der Trainer ist dann das einfachere und natürlich auch das günstigere Opfer, aber es ist dann letztendlich ja auch immer noch purer Aktionismus, weil man von etwas, von dem man Monate vorher noch überzeugt war, nämlich das reicht für eine Vertragsverlängerung, ist man auf einmal nicht mehr überzeugt, und gibt dafür ja durchaus signifikante Summen an Geld aus, um jemand anderen ran zu holen, das finde ich immer schwierig. So da, so dieses, ja, das so anzugehen. Und wenn man davon so überzeugt ist, dass man einen Vertrag mit einem Trainer verlängert im Sommer, dann ja, sagst du es vielleicht ganz richtig, aber vielleicht hat man diesen Komfort, diese Zeit nicht, einfach zu sagen, okay, hier sind mehrere Sachen auch in der Transferpolitik vielleicht falsch gelaufen, wir müssen das jetzt gemeinsam durchziehen und nehmen dann nächste Saison nochmal Anlauf. Dafür muss man aber auch die Gewissheit haben, okay, wir steigen dieses Jahr nicht ab, wir können uns das leisten, das durchzuziehen. Und das wäre dann sozusagen die Bereitschaft, die man vielleicht auch mal mitbringen muss als Team und die auch tatsächlich auch alle wünschen sich, dass man Heidenheim oder Freiburg ist, was die Trainerposition angeht. Ich meine, Freiburg, was haben die mit Christian Streich durchgemacht, also das muss man sich dann ja auch mal anschauen. Heidenheim ist auch fast abgestiegen mit Frank Schmidt in einem Jahr und die haben trotzdem da festgehalten und sind da trotzdem irgendwie durchgegangen. Und ja, ich glaube, häufig ist diese Fehlerkultur im Fußballverein ein großes Problem und Trainer raus Schmiss immer ein Zeichen dafür, dass es nicht nur auf der Trainerposition Probleme gibt.
Zumal, wenn du die Arbeit von diesem Trainer seit zwei Jahren kennst und du weißt, er war schon mal in der Krise, ist er meist wieder einigermaßen rausgekommen. Also ich kann es verstehen, wenn so etwas wie in Bielefeld du einen neuen Trainer holst und nach vier Spieltagen merkst, funktioniert gar nicht, dann finde ich einen Trainerwechsel okay im laufenden Betrieb. Aber so immer kompliziert wirkt es immer so ein bisschen, als würde man sich vor allem selbst aus der Schusslinie nehmen. Und das ist halt wirklich so dieser alte Fußball, jetzt kommt mal neuer Impuls und alle wieder kratzen, beißen. Und da weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht inzwischen ein bisschen überholt ist. Zumal es jetzt wirklich sind 11 Spieltage rum, also es ist noch nicht so weit. Du hast bald die WM-Pause und sowas, kannst dir da nochmal überlegen, ob du vielleicht nochmal komplett was anders machen willst. Aber das hat immer so den Hauch von Panikmodus, finde ich.
Zumal ja die Abstände noch gering sind. Also zwischen Platz 10 und Platz 16, über den wir jetzt gerade sprechen, liegen drei Punkte. Und zwischen Platz 10 und Platz 18 liegen nur fünf Punkte. Also sprich, da ist alles noch so, wie es ja auch häufig ist in diesem Stadium der Saison, noch sehr eng beieinander. Das betrifft jetzt auch die letzten beiden Teams, über die wir noch kurz sprechen wollen. Wir bleiben noch ein bisschen bei dir, Fadi, in deinem Einzugsbereich. Du hast es ja schon vorher gesprochen, dass du gerade im Zentrum der guten Laune der Liga bist, weil du eingeklemmt bist zwischen dem 1. FC Nürnberg auf Platz 16 und der Spielvereinigung Kräuterfurt auf Platz 17. Und da haben wir ja genau diesen Fall. Wir haben einen neuen Trainer, Mark Schneider, mit dem man einige Hoffnungen verbunden hat. Wir haben vor allem jemanden, der gegangen ist, mit Leitel zu Hannover 96. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer haben es mitbekommen. Wie würdest du denn jetzt dann so ein Zwischenfazit ziehen? Fürth ist die einzige Mannschaft, die nur einmal gewinnen konnte in elf Spielen, aber immerhin sechs unentschieden. Also dadurch ja neun Punkte geholt.
Ja, da stehe ich jetzt leider ein bisschen unter dem Einfluss, meines Kollegen Michael Fischer, der einen sehr einsamen Kampf für einen Trainerwechsel in Fürth führt, bislang aus seiner Sicht noch erfolglos. Schwierig. Die Spielmeinung Fürth ist ja einigermaßen furios in die Saison gestartet, zwar nur 2 zu 2 gegen Holstein Kiel im ersten Heimspiel, aber mit einem Torschussverhältnis von irgendwie so 1 Milliarde zu 2. Dieses Spiel nicht gewonnen und es gab dann so einen kleinen Knacks, glaube ich, danach, dass der Derby verloren in Nürnberg, was den Fürthern alle 30 Jahre mal passiert, dass sie das nicht gewinnen. Dann hat sich so ein bisschen die Stimmung gewandelt, Pokal aus noch bei den Stuttgarter Kickers nach einem wirklich schlechten Spiel. Und jetzt ist von diesem Fürther-Flachpass, den sie in Fürth so gerne feiern, da bilden sie sich ja zu Recht immer einiges auf die Spielstärke ihrer Mannschaften an. Jetzt ist einfach nicht mehr viel davon da. Beim Sieg zuletzt gegen Paderborn, beim ersten Saisonsieg, gab es dann einen sehr destruktiven Ansatz, der dann auch noch Erfolg hatte, was dazu führt, dass er beibehalten wird. Und ja, große Unzufriedenheit in Fürth. Rashid Azusi, der Sportdirektor, hält aber mit erstaunlicher Coolness noch an Marc Schneider fest.
Was ja, wenn wir so ein bisschen das, was wir gerade gesprochen haben, transferieren, auch nicht so schlimm sein muss.
Was nicht so schlimm sein muss, was aber wieder dem widerspricht, wenn ein Trainer neu in eine Stadt oder zu einem Verein kommt und man sieht, es funktioniert nicht, dann darf man, finde ich, nach dem Keblawi-Gesetz, dann darf man. In Fürth weigern sie sich noch, sagen, fünf Punkte aus den letzten drei Spielen ist okay, geht aufwärts. Ja, es ist spannend, aber wie gesagt, es trägt nicht zur guten Laune hier in der Region bei, dass die Spielvereinigung, also bei den Clubfans wahrscheinlich freuen sich die meisten doch, dass die Spielvereinigung noch hinter dem Club steht, aber ja, so. Für das Arbeiten in der Sportredaktion ist es gerade ein bisschen schwierig. Ich bin gespannt, es ist erstaunlich, dass Marc Schneider, obwohl er wirklich viel Kritik auch von uns abbekommt, immer noch ein sehr freundlicher, netter Gesprächspartner ist. Ich habe den Michael Fischer jetzt zwei- dreimal vertreten. Und wirklich ein sehr netter Mensch, Marc Schneider, aber halt im Moment noch kein erfolgreicher vierter Fußballtrainer.
Das geht leider nicht immer Hand in Hand, aber vielleicht kann das noch so werden. Du hast es ja auch gerade schon angesprochen, diese Unentschieden, also diese Punkte, die man jetzt doch zuletzt gesammelt hat. Also es gab ein 2 zu 1 gegen Paderborn, es gab ein 1 zu 1 gegen Sandhausen, jetzt ein 2 zu 2 gegen den Jan und ja auch ein 2 zu 2 Tim gegen St. Pauli, wo man vielleicht so eins der Probleme von Furt sehen konnte, nämlich egal eigentlich wie Spiele laufen, man kann sich nie sicher sein, ob Furt nicht irgendwie die Punkte noch wegschmeißt oder zumindest die Mehrfachpunkte wegschmeißt. Wie hast denn du da die Spielvereinigung erlebt?
Also auf jeden Fall als einen fast schon klassischen Absteiger, das kann man wahrscheinlich schon so sagen, also nicht Absteiger aus der 2. Liga, sondern ein Team, das oben runterkommt in die neue Liga.
Ich bin auch so erschrocken. Erzählt mir nämlich Michael Fischer die ganze Zeit, dass er als Absteiger aus der 2. Liga sieht. Also gut.
Ja, nein, so weit gehe ich noch nicht, aber es ist tatsächlich schon so, man muss einfach sagen, dass Bielefeld, zu denen kommen wir ja gleich noch, und die haben einfach diese typischen Anpassungsprobleme, die Teams nun mal haben, wenn sie aus der 1. Liga abgestiegen sind und dann eben sich in gewisser Art und Weise personell neu aufstellen müssen. Auf der Trainerbank haben sich beide ja auch neu aufgestellt und dann aber auch an den Fußball erst mal gewöhnen müssen, der da gespielt wird. Und dann eben gute Beispiele sind Regensburg, Sankt Hausen. Da kommen dann auf einmal Teams, die echt so gar keinen Bock haben auf eigene Spielkultur, Spielkontrolle. Und das ist in der 1. Liga, auch wenn es da auch viele Teams gibt, die den Ball gerne weggeben, ja doch noch schon mal ein bisschen was anderes ist. Und das haben alle Teams gehabt. Schalke und Werder Bremen waren letzte Saison, haben sie beide für ihre Verhältnisse eigentlich fast eine Hinrunde zum Vergessen gespielt. Und diese Probleme hätte ich jetzt bei Bielefeld und Führert auch ausgemacht zu Beginn. Also nach drei, vier Spielen konnte man auch sagen, ja das ist dieses typische Anpassungsproblem. Jetzt inzwischen sind sie ja glaube ich die schlechtesten Absteiger aus der ersten Liga seit Jahren. Und ich habe die Statistik auch schmerzhaft mitbekommen, weil sie sind die schlechtesten Absteiger seit dem FC St. Pauli 2002, 2003. Da ist St. Pauli nämlich dann direkt weiter durchgereicht worden in die dritte Liga. Ich finde die Herangehensweisen auch interessant, weil sie beide unterschiedlich sind. Rashida Sousi da in Fürth hält das, was er da auch gewählt hat, an Worten stark am Trainer fest, während da in Bielefeld schon ziemlich schnell die Reißleine gezogen wird. Und so richtig was gebracht hat es in Bielefeld noch nicht. Was Spielkultur angeht, da ist Fürth tatsächlich ein Team, bei dem ich sagen würde, die versuchen auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge, aber es funktioniert momentan relativ wenig. Da kann ich gar nicht sagen, wo da irgendwie personell vielleicht was fehlt. Vielleicht ist auch eine Idee der Spielidee oder ein Problem der Spielidee, dass da noch nicht ein Rad ins andere läuft. Personell würde man sie oder würde ich sie da unten auf jeden Fall nicht verorten. Das gilt aber für Bielefeld ganz genauso und für Nürnberg auch und für den FC St. Pauli auch. Stehen trotzdem alle unten.
Na, na, na, na. Du geh mal wieder an die Sonne, tank ein bisschen D12, dann bist du wieder ein bisschen positiver. Das kann ja gerade nicht so positiv sein bei dir. Es ist natürlich keine schöne Situation. Platz 17 und 18 für Fürth und für Bielefeld. Aber punktetechnisch ist noch alles drin. Ich finde das interessant und bin dir dankbar, Tim, dass du diesen Punkt nochmal aufgemacht hast. Anpassungsschwierigkeiten haben wir schon häufig gesehen und in unterschiedlicher Güteklasse. Natürlich kann man da dann auch die Reißleine ziehen, wenn man das Gefühl hat, ein Trainer selbst kann mit diesen Anpassungsproblemen nicht umgehen, die auch ein ganzes Team für sich hat. Aber man kann eben auch durchaus in der Vergangenheit sehen, dass man da das Ruder herumreißen kann, auch wenn es jetzt eine Floskel ist und auch wenn das schmerzhafte Anpassungsmomente sind. Aber auch da, wir haben eine lange Winterpause, die auch die 2. Liga betrifft, da gibt es ja die Möglichkeit dann durchaus zu reagieren. Ich rechne eigentlich fest damit, dass die Rückrunde noch weniger vergleichbar zur Hinrente sein wird als sonst in der Liga. Und es betrifft ja auch Bielefeld. Wir sind jetzt auch direkt auch schon im Bielefeld-Bereich dann gelandet. Fadi, welche Unterschiede würdest du denn jetzt zwischen Fürth und Bielefeld sehen? Also Tim hat ja gerade schon ein paar aufgemacht. Unter anderem eben, dass man am einen Standort, nämlich Bielefeld, nicht am Trainer festgehalten hat. Kurz sah es ja auch so aus, als hätte man damit eine super Entscheidung getroffen. Jetzt jüngst aber dann doch nicht mehr so positiv alles bei der Armenia.
Also das wirklich nur sehr, sehr aus der Ferne beurteilt. Aber ich glaube, dass tatsächlich in Bielefeld die Panik nochmal einiges größer ist als in Fürth. Ich habe am Wochenende jetzt ein kurzes Interview mit Sami Arabi gesehen. Dagegen raschete der Susi das blühende Leben. Das sah nicht mehr so ganz souverän aus in Bielefeld. Andererseits haben die ersten Ergebnisse, wie du sagst, nach diesem Trainerwechsel tatsächlich eher schon für sie gesprochen und für diesen Schritt.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass man schon unterscheiden muss zwischen Bielefeld und Fürth. Allein schon, wie sie in die 1. Liga gekommen sind. Bielefeld war ja auch schon ein Jahr länger in der 1. Liga. Was den Kader angeht, auch was Kaderqualität angeht, war schon eine ganze Ecke weiter als Fürth. Fürth ist ja im Grunde der Aufstiegskader, war ja nur noch zur Hälfte da, als sie in der 1. Liga gespielt haben. Das muss man ja auch mal ganz rational betrachten, dass Greuther Fürth fast ein bisschen chancenlos gewesen ist und jetzt im Grunde ja wirklich ganz bei Null anfängt, während in Bielefeld ja schon super viele Abgänge. Ich will das auch gar nicht schönreden, aber schon so ein bisschen versucht wurde, da auch einiges an Qualität zu halten bzw. das Level zu halten. Und da die Ansprüche vielleicht auch schon noch so ein bisschen andere waren als bei Fürth. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo an einem der beiden Standorte gesagt wurde, wir wollen direkt wieder aufsteigen. Aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass so in Bielefeld strukturell vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr die Hoffnung da ist, dass man ein bisschen besser in die Saison startet. Grundsätzlich ist es aber natürlich so, man muss ja auch sagen, auch Schalke und Werder haben innerhalb der letzten Saison den Trainer gewechselt und hatten diese Anpassungsprobleme. Und ich wiederhole mich da gerne. Also ich glaube, in der zweiten Liga ist es, wenn du da erstmal in so einen Lauf reinkommst, erstmal zwei, drei Spiele gewinnst, den Negativlauf kannst du halt auch haben, da kannst du auch reinkommen. Aber dann geht das relativ fix. Und jetzt können wir den Bogen wieder zum Anfang der Sendung schlagen, weil jetzt ist der HSV relativ weit vorne, aber aufgestiegen sind sie eben noch nicht. Und das Frühjahr zeigt ja dann tatsächlich doch immer wieder, dass der HSV ja vielleicht dann doch nochmal ein paar Probleme bekommt und andere Teams da doch sehr viel näher ranrücken können, als es jetzt zum Beispiel gerade aktuell aussieht. Und St. Pauli war letzte Saison auch so unfassbar weit vorne und hat glaube ich in der Rückrunde irgendwie 13 Punkte allein auf Schalke 04 verloren. Also so unfassbare Zahlen. Und da kann also noch viel gehen und ich glaube persönlich nicht, dass das für Fürth und Bielefeld gerade was so Abstieg angeht, dass das nochmal ein Thema wird bei denen. Ich glaube, die werden sich irgendwie da wieder ranziehen. Muss aber auch ehrlich sagen, und da muss ich dann vielleicht deinem Kollegen, dem werten Herrn Fischer ein bisschen beiflichten, wenn eins der beiden Teams größere Probleme bekommt, dann dürfte es Kreuter Fürth sein.
Na, mit dieser positiven Note.
Ja, ich bin begeistert, dass Tim das noch geschafft hat, trotz meiner Bemühungen hier schlechte Laune zu verbreiten. Und dann gehen wir hier positiv gestimmt aus dem Podcast raus. Das ist sensationell.
Naja, nicht alle, glaube ich, positiv gestimmt. Aber ich meine, da wird es dann, vielleicht mache ich wirklich diesen Kurzpass, den es ja eigentlich geben muss. Also Eva und Michi Fischer, Eva Lottabole und Michi Fischer, die sind ja Stammbesetzung schon in der Erstligasaison gewesen im letzten Jahr. Vielleicht muss ich das einfach im Kurzpass nochmal rausholen als Weihnachtsgeschenk dann irgendwie am Ende dieser Hinrunde. War jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so geplant, aber vielleicht lohnt da nochmal ein näherer Blick hin. Ich bin euch beiden aber sehr dankbar, dass ihr euch jetzt die Zeit genommen habt, so genau auf so viele Teams zu blicken. Und eben nicht nur auf eure so genau. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Das hat große Freude gemacht. Ich denke auch den Hörern und Hörern, die auch bemerkt haben jetzt aktuell auch auf das zweite Feedback wird und euch bin ich gleich eingegangen. Das zweite Feedback von euch nach dem letzten Kurzpass war nämlich Länge des Kurzpasses ist uns – ich sag's einfach mal – scheißegal und dementsprechend habe ich das jetzt auch hier einfach laufen lassen. Ganz herzlichen Dank, dass ich das tun durfte. An Tim Ecksteen vom Millern-Ton. Folgt ihm alle als Tim-Ecksteen auf Twitter. Tim, danke dir, dass du dich mal wieder durch Statistiken gewöhnt hast, dir 1000 Tabs aufgeöffnet hast. Wahrscheinlich allein für diese Aufnahme hat wieder große Freude gemacht, dich hier im Rasenfunk zu haben.
Ja, sehr gern. Hat mich auch sehr gefreut.
Das ist schön zu hören. Und ganz herzlichen Dank auch an Fadi Keblawi von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und natürlich dem Fußballpodcast. Kadeb, der AtGoPunkHurst auf Twitter. Danke dir, Fadi, ein grandioses Rasenfunk-Debüt. Du hast hier, obwohl du es anders proklamiert hast, gute Laune reingebracht, finde ich zumindest.
Tatsächlich, das freut mich sehr.
Sehr gerne, kommen gerne wieder und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es gibt im Rasenfunk noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Sendungen, die ihr euch anhören könntet. Wir haben ein Tribüngespräch zum Beispiel aufgenommen zum Missbrauchsskandal in der NWSL. Und natürlich machen wir auch Sendungen zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zur 1. Bundesliga der Männer. Klickt euch einfach mal ein bisschen rum auf rasenfunk.de und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald hier wieder. Bis dahin bleibt gesund, macht es gut und unterstützt uns gerne, wenn ihr mögt. Bis bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk.